>> Bret: REPUBLICANS ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE ARE
TAKING THE NEXT STEP TRYING TO
PROVE THE DEMOCRAT FUNDED TRUMP
DOSSIER WAS WRONGLY USED AS
JUSTIFICATION FOR MUCH OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO ALLEGED
COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE SHOWS US THE
LATEST.
>> CURRENT AND FORMER GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS INCLUDING FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN AND FORMER
INTELLIGENCE CHIEF JAMES CLAPPER
HAVE UNTIL FRIDAY TO TELL THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
WHEN THEY KNEW THE TRUMP DOSSIER
WAS FUNDED BY THE DNC AND
CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
SUBPOENAS ARE IN PLAY.
>> IF THEY DON'T ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS TRUTHFULLY AND FULLY
PAID >> RESPONDING TO REPUBLICAN
ALLEGATIONS THAT THE FBI AND
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WERE GUILTY
OF SURVEILLANCE'S ABUSES.
THE COUNTER MEMO RELEASED OVER
THE WEEKEND WITH REDACTIONS AT
THE FBI'S REQUEST.
DEMOCRATS CONCLUDE THERE WAS
INTELLIGENCE BEYOND THE TRUMP
DOSSIER TO JUSTIFY SURVEILLANCE
OF A CAMPAIGN AIDE.
>> THE FBI ACTED APPROPRIATELY
SEEKING A WARRANT FOR CARTER
PAGE.
THEY ARE NOT PART OF SOME DEEP
STATE.
>> DEMOCRATS HAD MULTIPLE
SOURCES CORROBORATE THE DOSSIER
ALLEGATIONS.
THIS APPEARS TO CONFLICT WITH
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY'S 2017 CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY.
THREE MONTHS AFTER THE PAID
SURVEILLANCE -- PAGE
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT, COMEY